you and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hello there I'm Rosanna Lockwood on
uncensored tonight Rishi sunak gets mean
on green as he launches an expansion of
oil and gas exploration and says Banning
everything is not the answer to climate
change but with record heat waves in
Europe will Britain find itself on the
wrong side of History we're going to be
debating that an estimated 150 000 Brits
went to turkey last year for cheap
cosmetic surgery worth billions for that
country but with more and more patients
having botched procedures should the NHS
and the taxpayer bear the cost of fixing
patients problems
and the Gen Z women doing quote Lazy
Girl jobs a new anti-work movement is
taking Tick Tock by storm with women in
particular boasting about getting paid
well to do the bare minimum
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
now Net Zero when I say those two words
what do you think do you think yeah cool
something we've all got to do to save
the planet or do you think nonsense a
sham a lie we're being sold that's going
to make us all poorer that we have these
same fiery debates about climate change
every summer now when we witness more
wildfires and heat waves around the
world but yes I know I know it's pouring
with rain in the UK at the moment it
feels more like Autumn so global warming
isn't real and what about those
historical weather patterns and El Nino
those charts people can point to to
reassure themselves this is all Hokum
and par for the course because who
really wants to believe that we're
making the planet uninhabitable through
our actions when top scientists have
been warning us for years about the
danger of burning fossil fuels into the
atmosphere because it doesn't feel nice
does it to admit that that it's scary
quite frankly and it means we're all
somehow at fault for driving cars we're
taking planes and eating intensively
farmed food and we're just trying to
live a nice life aren't we we're only
here for a short time and things were
seemingly fine up until a few years ago
some people are struggling to pay rent
now there's a housing crisis and the
cost of basic food items is going
through the roof so it's easier to just
call the Net Zero stuff bogus or a scam
or even a conspiracy to control the way
we live
but I am not here to insult your
intelligence like that I know you know
there is a difference between global
climate change and the daily weather
patterns here in Britain and I know a
lot of you actually care about it even
if just for a little bit here in Britain
I think we're generally pretty good at
doing our part taking out the recycling
listening to scientists doing what we
can to help others and it's not like
we're in control of a lot of this stuff
either it's the private companies we buy
the stuff from or the politicians we
vote into Power recent polling actually
showing a majority of conservative
voters considering switching to labor
think that Rishi sunak has not done
enough to tackle climate change and as
if to double down today prime minister
sunac announcing more than 100 new
drilling licenses for oil and gas in the
North Sea a huge investment into fossil
fuels at a time when other countries are
turning away the thing is I think most
of us want to keep taking planes to go
on holiday don't we to escape this wet
little island we call home and trust me
me included I just came back from a
holiday we want to keep driving our much
loved cars and I think that's where a
lot of this debate comes from we feel
attacked for our choices so we look for
a narrative that makes us feel better
and I'm not here to preach I'm not here
to make you feel better or make you feel
worse about those choices I'm in exactly
the same boat as you I just think we
need to find a way to live with all this
while not choosing to be stupid because
we don't like the truth
if we can have some calm analysis of the
facts without hysteria from either side
whether it be just stop oil or the
anti-net zero Brigade if we can order to
stop attacking each other for the
decisions we make then we can all be
better informed make the choices we want
based on that information and keep an
eye on the future we're leaving behind
and I think we would all appreciate that
so what will Britain's Legacy be in this
debate and is the government now moving
backwards in its approach to tackling
climate change I know what I think oh
let's see what these people think I'm
joined by associate editor of the mirror
Kevin McGuire Harry Wilkinson head of
policy at Net Zero watch and just stop
oil protester Alex De kerning joining us
from down the line Alex as you're there
I'll start with you just talk to me a
little bit about what you thought when
you heard this government announcement
today about these hundred or so licenses
for drilling in the North Sea
well first of all Rosanna thank you for
having me on the show and I really loved
your introduction you got so many things
right
um you're right the everyday person
doesn't want to you know give up their
cars give up their planes and we're not
asking people to ultimately the
responsibility shouldn't be on the
everyday person it should be on the
government who are betraying Us by
opening up these over a hundred new oil
and gas licenses I was livid when I saw
that this is a direct it's like almost
active war against the young people and
the people on the global South who are
going to suffer first from the climate
crisis we as you say we've seen the
wildfires we've seen 40 degree weather
in the UK we know it's going to keep
getting worse and worse it's about time
that we'd started trying to do something
in order to stop it from happening we
need to stop all new oil and gas in line
with what Laura Devon the former um
ahead of the climate change committee
has said before he retired because Rishi
sunak wasn't doing his part in line with
what the cross parliamentary
environmental committee said in line
with what the UN is saying the
International Energy agency this is not
a party issue we all want a livable
future and we should be striving for
that we should be working together
against the government who are now
pushing through these frankly criminal
policies Alex thank you I want to come
back to you and talk about the role that
just stop oil has played in this debate
obviously you're speaking on behalf of
them today so you will come back from
that I want to come to Harry in the
studio now and just talk about uh Net
Zero as a term like you work for Net
Zero watch it's a sort of policy group
um and do you think it's all Holcomb
it's all bogus no absolutely not we
should be concerned about climate change
but we should have policies that protect
people's lives that mean that they can
still do the things that they've been
used to doing uh at an affordable price
I think Richardson was quite right to
say today that Net Zero shouldn't mean
Banning things it shouldn't mean an
unfair cost burden and that's what we
believe in and I think it's right that
he's finally woken up to this the
political class just for too long hasn't
actually been dealing with the cost of
Net Zero they've been talking about
ambition they've been talking about what
can we do to tackle climate change but
they haven't been thinking about the
costs there's now more of a cost of that
and when it comes to the uh licenses for
oil and gas in the North Sea we have to
make a choice do we want this oil and
gas to come from Russia Qatar do we want
it to come from domestic sources we
still rely on 75 of our energy needs
come from fossil fuels so if we say no
to our own supplies it just means bring
it in from elsewhere yeah Harry I can
get behind this
Supply security point of view here Kevin
I'll come to you on this because you
know it's easy for us to understand now
since uh the recent war in Ukraine and
what we saw happen to Energy prices and
we know we need to generate more energy
from the United Kingdom so we don't need
to import it all in I can buy that
argument what I necessarily can't buy is
that it should be fossil fuels
no well Harry's group is hostile to
measures and the Net Zero Target so it's
not just an independent research
organization and questions have been
raised about the funding and who funds
the commercial interest funding funding
that no there is an issue of energy
Security in fact the government which is
soon like set up a department of energy
security and Net Zero you can see which
comes first where his emphasis is and we
at the moment import about 40 of our oil
47 of our gas but we don't control what
comes out the North Sea in fact Greg
hands a former energy Minister who is
now chair of the Tory party saying more
gas coming out won't reduce your bill
because it just goes into it
International exactly it's not as if
it's nationalized now what's wrong here
I think the sunac and most of those 100
licenses won't produce a drop of oil or
a whiff of gas they will just fail the
North Sea itself is actually pretty
pumped out now there's is very little
left because we've been extracting it
for for so long but what he's basically
saying this is is going to be a fossil
fool he's going to be a prime minister
sticking with fossil fuels rather than
trying to make that jump to Renewables
and for instance wind turbines on land
the cheapest most secure form of
electricity and yet the Tory part is
full of nimbies who just oppose that
this is this is where he's getting it
wrong this is before you even think
about saving the planet you're just
thinking about your own Energy bill
Harry talks about cost well if we're
going to have cost we'd have more wind
turbines we wouldn't be drilling in the
North Sea uh oh Harry I'll give you a
chance but Alex I know you wanted to
join in there as you're listening to
Kevin I also want to talk just generally
about this being a political move
because obviously the current government
want to stay in power and they think
this is going to be the way forward
because and some would say this that the
actions of organized Nations like just
stop oil have politicized this debate so
much and cause some people to turn
against the climate change cause so the
government are riding off the back of
this basically and pursuing this huge
fossil fuel policy
uh well no I don't think that is just
thought well it has been politicizing
this issue I think that the government
are deliberately trying to politicize it
themselves
um but I think that title will turn when
people realize that it takes an average
of 28 years to get oil and gas from the
North Sea after granting a license 28
years we cannot wait 28 years we all
know how bad the climate crisis is right
now we've seen the wildfires and Roads
we've seen the orange guys in New York
we've seen how higher energy bills are
we simply cannot wait 28 years and I
think once people are realized that
they're being lied to by this government
they're going to be Furies and they too
are going to start coming onto the
streets and joining other groups like
just stop oil like Extinction Rebellion
are they going to vote labor or they're
going to do whatever they can because
honestly it's a farce they're
subsidizing millions and millions of
pounds into North Sea oil and gas even
though as uh one of the gases correctly
said onshore when is by far the cheapest
form of energy and is being banned right
now Harry I want to come to you on the
sort of the business and the political
rationale for this because there has
been some reception internationally
today of this of the Britain's decision
to do this and Sue next government
decision that it's not the right
direction to be moving in for investment
in the future of the United Kingdom it's
obviously not the right decision for
climate change worldwide uh no no doubt
about that because it's fossil fuels but
it just proves that it's a sort of we're
a country trapped in the past we're
still trying to generate fossil fuel
jobs absolutely not it shows we're being
realistic about our energy needs there
are plenty of other countries that are
looking at their own energy supplies
it's not an either or it doesn't stop us
looking into Renewables if we make sure
that to North Sea oil and gas can still
be exploited and we have to remember
there's 200 000 plus jobs mainly in
Scotland that are dependent on this
industry do we just want to let them see
those jobs go or do we actually want to
give time for people to reskill and to
have a productive economy if Britain
does Net Zero expensively who is going
to want to copy us you look at America's
approach that many people have been
saying that we should copy of
subsidizing all of these green
Industries but the developing world
can't do that you know they can't afford
these huge subsidies if we want to
promote an approach that other countries
can copy it has to be based off
competition we have to discover the most
reliable green technologies by allowing
them to compete against each other yeah
reliable green technologies I'm with you
on that absolutely Uh Kevin wouldn't you
rather see this type of investment and
job creation in hydrogen capture yeah
carbon capture are the hydrogen and
Renewables yeah well carbon capture is
promoted by the oil and gas companies to
try and keep themselves in in business
we would still be literally burning the
planet digging it out and burning it
which is what we've been doing for
centuries and look that 1.5 Target which
scientists say the Earth hits but by 1.5
percent compared to pre-industrial
levels you'll get these massive weather
changes which you'll either have dry or
you'll have floods you'll have storms
well we're about 1.2 percent already
there look we're about 80 percent of the
way of that Target it might be exceeded
now the way to invest is in Renewables
and nuclear power that is the way now
there's problems with waste nuclear
power won't deny that but you get a
great big base load we've just got to
stop this idea of being hooked on fossil
fuels I mean look we gotta we're going
to move with the future we can't be in
the dinosaur age forever yeah uh Alex I
want to give you the last word on this
because you've joined us outside of the
studio this evening but uh Net Zero is
becoming a really uh some would argue
toxic term because of the way that it's
been characterized currently in the
median part of the debate how do you
turn the ship around
well we don't need the term Net Zero Net
Zero is commonly associated with Net
Zero by 2050. 2050 is too late to do any
action we all know that 27 years from
now is too late so we need to be talking
about Renewables we're talking about the
cleaner air we can get from that the
lower energy what we've been talking
about insulation and the warmer holes we
can have and the cheaper public
transport is going to help people take
trains as opposed to drivers often we
need to be talking about a positive
vision of the future and not promoting
these lies about North Sea oil and gas
we don't need it it's as simple as that
there's no economic reason there's no
moral reason let's just move on with the
debate look just stop oil are going to
stop the disruption as soon as all these
North Sea oil and gas license install
and we all want the same thing so let's
all pressure the government in order to
make sure this stops and then just stop
oil and stuff and we can all go on with
our days and live happy lives doesn't
that sound better Alex can you admit
though that just stop oil
um isn't the most popular organization
in the UK I mean what what's what's next
to you guys how are you going to turn
that ship around
well this isn't about popularity um
Rishi sunak isn't popular I think we're
actually even more popular than Rishi
sunak at the moment
um so a lot of history and has shown
that social movements don't need to be
popular to make change but we're really
trying to hard to make the connection
between oil and gas and the climate
events that we're seeing now and we're
trying to highlight the hypocrisy that
Rishi sunak is making all these lies and
so yeah we're going to keep doing what
we're doing because it is working every
other major political party has said no
new oil and gas and it's really starting
to help turn the turn the tide Harry
Alex Kevin thank you all very much for
joining me really interesting debate
thank you well and I'm censored next
tonight over 100 Brits needed emergency
NHS care after returning from places
like turkey in 2022 to go under the
knife so are the cheaper prices worth it
and who should bear the cost for surgery
gone wrong that coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to face Morgan uncensored
me Rosanna Lockwood sitting in the chair
for the next few weeks now taxpayers
last year spent a record 1.7 million
pounds on fixing Brits of botched by
cosmetic surgery carried out abroad with
one case costing it the NHS 100
000 pounds that was to fix a dodgy tummy
tuck cheap flights package deals surplus
of surgeries have all made turkey one of
the top destinations for Brits desperate
for the body of their dreams but at what
cost British cosmetic surgeons are now
accusing their Turkish counterparts of
using the NHS as a taxpayer-funded
safety net for their poor after care so
who should be picking up the bill for
these surgeries let's talk to two people
who have undergone surgeries in Turkey
but who had very different experiences
I'm joined by Sarah Platt who underwent
weight loss surgery that unfortunately
went very wrong in Daily indeed also
joined by Denzel siegers we flew from
the U.S to under go leg lengthening
surgery also joining us thank you both
very much and live from Istanbul the
Turkish Cosmetics surgeon Dr erjin guban
and joining me in the studio to react
all this talk TV contributor Esther
kraku now Sarah I will come to you first
um because this story is about surgeries
that have gone wrong essentially and
coming back to the UK with those just
tell us what happened to you
um so I had weight loss surgery
um and that went totally fine and I lost
12 stone
um I needed it enough for I needed to
have health reasons I needed emergency
operation and I couldn't have it because
I was overweight um doing covered
um so after I'd lost all my my weight
because I lost it so quickly
um I was left with a saggy hanging
really bad skin
um and it was blistering it was rubbing
it was burning I couldn't deal with
anymore and I couldn't afford the price
in the UK so um I researched like for 17
months and I flew out to Turkey and
basically he left me in a complete and
at the mess
um he operated on me when I was awake
and they held me down
and um I've got complex PTSD from that
um I've been left with gaping holes in
my stomach and they've had to remove my
boobs
um I've been left with cuts across my
back
um that there wasn't even supposed to
happen anyway
um I can't lift my arms above my head
because he's taking too much skin off
he's taking too much skin off my stomach
so there's no way of closing my stomach
um and he's just totally destroyed me so
I'm so sorry to hear about that
experience
um absolutely traumatic
um thank you for sharing the details
with us as part of this story I just
want to ask you what advice you would
give to anyone else who is considering
um a procedure in Turkey because your
first one was successful
um it was successful but there was no
Aftercare there was no there was Zero
aftercare
um and then I was recommended obviously
to like the the price difference was
half the price in Turkey it was still 15
000 pounds but it was half the price of
the UK
um what I would say was don't you know
don't don't do it like it's it's
literally like Russian Roulette you
don't know what's gonna happen you
there's no regulations over there
there's nothing and they don't care once
they've got your money they do not care
they don't sorry thank you very much for
sharing your experience with us I want
to go to Dr urgent Google Now who joins
us from Turkey a cosmetic surgeon
listening to that story sir
um we're not saying that that is
representative of all surgery in Turkey
of course we're not uh but listening to
that story what does it make you think
does the people think that the in Turkey
the cosmetic surgery is very low cost
and they just think about the cost about
the surgery the people should think
about the results firstly and the
experienced surgeons they should find
very experienced surgeons in Turkey many
young surgeons do very low cost
operations here in Turkey but
the the operations result and mostly is
really successful in Turkey but the cost
is very different from hospital to
hospital if you find a high-class
Hospital you cannot find like this kind
of Hospital even in UK this is very high
class hospital we have in Turkey but you
should pay more than like the low cost
companies in Turkey the tourism agency
May make the some Health Organization in
Turkey but if you find some tourism
agency in Turkey you are going to have a
very low cost surgeries here so if you
if you directly reach to the surgeons
and connect with them they are going to
do the best things for you Sarah your
experience was an expensive one though
right yeah it's it's sorry but what
you're saying is totally rubbish I've
got to be honest because I researched
for 70 months I went I flew out last
year and visited eight different
surgeons literally the one I picked was
the most expensive he had amazing Clinic
amazing reviews and it still did not go
to plan so what it was not cheap it was
literally so it's gonna have to do that
I've seen all the hospitals and West
little clinics everything everything and
of course we'd like to restate that the
doctor joining us on the show today is
not the doctor that works with Sarah but
also you're just responding to the
comments made there um thank you sir
Let's cross now to Denzel as well who
actually had a very different experience
uh Denzel you had leg lengthening
surgery in Turkey talk us through what
that was like
so my experience with limb lengthening
surgery was actually amazing for me I
originally was going to get it in
America but they have a rehabilitation
center and they were much more costly so
after doing a bit more research about
two weeks before my appointment in
America I actually found a few centers
in turkey that did the process well one
that I stumbled upon that I did the most
research research into I actually found
habilitation Center and had like a ton
of successful surgeries so I flew out
like right after doing my research and
finding out about them I flew out and I
did my surgery there and I actually did
the surgery twice to get talk I did my
upper legs and lower legs and I've had a
very accessible experience with it just
in my recovery while I was there it was
actually my I've ever had and it was
very successful for me I couldn't be
happier with the results but when you
hear Sarah's story obviously a very very
different experience would that make you
think twice about pursuing more surgery
in turkey or advising other people to do
so
so I don't plan on getting any other
surgeries height was my only issue that
I had with myself really but the center
that I went through I would miss anyone
I've actually made a whole page and I
promote them on my social media just
because of my experience with them I
haven't seen any unsuccessful surgeries
I've only heard of one but I I couldn't
tell you much about their story it was
just some random person that messaged me
online but it's definitely not for
everyone it was the most painful process
I've ever been through but it was like I
said worth it for Me overall because
height was something that really stuck
with me
uh thank you very much Denzel for
sharing your story with us I want to
come to the studio now speak to Esther
who has been watching all of this with
me with stories
um you know and Sarah and Denzel are
still with us and obviously have had
very different experiences Sarah is
particularly traumatic uh when it comes
to people making the personal choice to
go have cosmetic surgery I want to
disclose I have had cosmetic surgery I
had a nose job in Dubai a few years ago
I was living there I didn't fly there
for it there you go that was my recovery
very painful
um I went from medical procedure and
they took off the bump on my nose while
I was in there no regrets at all I think
anyone should pursue cosmetic surgery
responsibly if they want to it can be
absolutely life-changing Esther
um but in terms of flying somewhere to
go do it what are your thoughts on that
I think if you understand the risks and
you are prepared for what comes with it
I think that's fine I think in the
context of the NHS because we're talking
about in in the context of you know the
NHS having to fit the bill for botch
surgeries I think that's a reality that
comes with socialized Healthcare I mean
if you really wanted to get to the Crux
of the issue I would we should be
talking about obesity and alcoholism
because these are choices that you know
people make well in the case of obesity
you can argue that it's linked to mental
health but at the end of the day you
know getting to that state is because of
personal choices and yet the NHS spends
most of its Budget on you know
rectifying lifestyle related illnesses
like this I think 1.7 million pounds for
botch surgeries is actually a steal if
we could exchange that for all the you
know costs that we spend on or the
amount of money that's spent on you know
lifestyle related illnesses I think the
NHS would be a much better State
um but the reality is at the end of the
day people have to take personal
responsibility for the choices that they
make you know you could go to a country
where you don't have any social support
you don't have any you know relatives
around you know after carers may or may
not exist and that's a risk that you
take by going abroad to get surgery so
these are all the things that people
need to consider absolutely and do you
think by the way that uh there should be
any advisory from the government or from
Health bodies or from plastic surgery
associations about turkey based on what
we're hearing um I don't think
necessarily because yes we usually use
the example of turkey because so popular
in common but you know increasingly
people are going to India for sort of
eye surgery the Middle East Dubai I've
heard of as well um so I think turkey
just because of you know it's what we
know but there are other places as well
that people go to at the end of the day
I think we become so infantilized as a
society that I don't think is necessary
for the government to say this is your
responsibility
um but I do think if we're concerned
about the repercussions um with regards
to the cost of the NHS we really should
be talking about obesity and alcoholism
as opposed to uh you know botched
surgeries Dr Gervin um I want to end
this discussion coming back to you
because again you're not representative
of all cosmetic surgeons you weren't
related to the bot surgery we were
talking about early on in the show
um but want to ask for your advice to
anyone considering uh flying not just a
turkey but to somewhere else in the
world for cosmetic surgery how should
that be done responsibly
I just wanna
recommend to the people UK people just
first time they should make interview
with the surgeons real interview like
because they need to see the environment
and the hospitals of the like surgery
going to do so it is very important to
talk with the surgeons it's it's not a
fine to share the photographs and have
some surgeries about the photographs you
need to talk with the surgeons and
interview with the surgeons consultation
and later decide about the surgery in
Turkey it is very important and the
first thing that we advise for the UK
people if you come to Turkey and to see
the hospitals if you look around the
hospitals and the environment
digitalization and
especially the Physicians experiment is
very important for the successful
surgery results that's very important
think your cosmetics surgery industry is
a positive part of turkey's reputation
yes because in Turkey there is many
Physicians that's well educated in
plastic surgery so you can find very
very high-end surgery
procedures in turkey and many surgeons
have a very good reputation in Turkey if
you can find good surgeons you can have
good results as well of course but there
are always of course examples of stories
like we had from Sarah this evening as
well I want to thank particularly our
two case studies who've shared their
stories of the city sour Platt and
Denzel siegas Dr goof and for your
Insight Esther here in the studio thanks
well uncensored next with swathes of
young women choosing quote Lazy Girl
jobs one Earth is motivating them to
turn their backs on good old fashion
hard work we'll be debating that next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war remember me cry again I'm trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
King Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me after church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman me
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
foreign
with me Rosanna Lockwood now we have all
heard of the work smarter not harder
concept haven't we but a new workplace
term is going viral on social media
which encourages women to achieve an
easier work-life balance coined the Lazy
Girl job content creators urge young
women to quietly quit their jobs and do
the bare minimum let's take a look
like a lazy girl job is like a job that
does not require an intense amount of
work I feel like it's laid back and also
there's a lot of jobs out there where
you could make like 60 to 80k so like
pretty comfortable salaries and not do
that much work and be remote so I have
one of those lazy girl jobs that's why I
make videos while I'm sitting at Target
waiting on my order in the middle of the
day working two hours instead of eight
hours and you're on a salary so you
still get paid regardless and then you
can go do whatever you want called Lazy
Girl jobs not because we're being lazy
well joining me now to discuss all of
this socialist commentator and author
Grace Blakely uh Grace I mean uh when
you're watching that I personally find
it a little bit aspirational I'm not
gonna lie I know I've got the kind of
job a lot of people would kill for but
it's certainly not a lazy girl job
um and when I saw those tick tocks and
see these girls sort of saying basically
take an admin job get a salaries you can
clock in as few hours as possible and
just slope off home I mean I kind of I
slightly support it oh totally I
completely support it I mean I've
currently lost my voice slightly
um as you can tell from enjoying my life
because there is a lot more to life than
just working and I think we have this
kind of attitude where
um you know we expect people to
basically kind of suffer as a form of
virtue and that that's like you know the
best thing to do is to work as hard as
possible and to not take time off but
actually
um yeah I think you know there is so
much more to life than work and these
people are clearly enjoying their lives
as I have been as you can hear we can we
can tell we can hear from that and you
know I say it's aspirational to have a
lazy girl job but of course I've worked
my socks off uh to get right here and I
do also uh follow the economy and
business quite closely understand that
you know we need jobs to turn the
economy around so I'm being slightly
tried and on that I want to bring in
Shark Tank star businessman Kevin
O'Leary Uh Kevin The Lazy Girl job
phenomenon uh haven't they just found a
really smart way to hack the system
you know we've seen this movie before it
was called quiet quitting only 18 months
ago and it was multi-gender at that time
it wasn't just lazy girls it was
everybody and the economy was coming
through worldwide pandemic and new work
models were emerging and so we deal with
this every day I've got portfolio
companies 34 different companies 40
percent of our employees have not
returned to work primarily in areas such
as accounting Logistics and compliance
and now social media support we have
virtually no one in that category that
works out of an office they work from
all around the world but here's the
point I want to make whether you're a
lazy girl or your quiet quitter doesn't
matter because you either perform your
task on a project basis in other words
if you're releasing your quarterly
financial statements next Thursday at 12
noon and you're the head of finance and
you're working remotely from another
country nobody care shares how you get
it done or what time you do it in it's
just that do you release the statements
on time for compliance and so the whole
world is watching this happen and so are
young and old people and saying wait a
second from my job I don't need to sit
in the cubicle I'm going to be a lazy
girl I'm going to be a quiet quitter but
I'm going to get my job done and I'm
going to get paid and so I'm paying
plenty of people more than eighty
thousand dollars a year or Euros in the
case of my employees in Europe or pounds
you know or any of the European
countries or Asian countries or Middle
East countries that they work with us
and they're making lots of money but
they're getting it done on a project
basis so I wouldn't be too concerned
about this now if you're just lazy and
you can't get anything done I'm gonna
fire your ass and I do that all the time
like Rick Grace surely I mean that's
fair someone's not performing their work
and they're boasting about being lazy
they've been filming tick tocks at work
about how lazy they are don't they
deserve to be fired look I don't
disagree with a lot of what we've just
heard because as long as you are getting
your tasks done on a project basis
that's what we should care about we have
a big problem actually in the economy of
low productivity so that's people often
actually being employed for long periods
of time and often not doing very much or
not adding very much value because they
were forced to sit in an office where
you know they weren't necessarily
contributing a lot they were just
sitting you know doing small tasks and
trying to fill up the day whereas
actually as we move towards homeworking
where people perhaps have more control
over their time you get the combination
of potentially higher productivity
because they're doing more and less time
and a better work-life balance which
means they're kind of happier having you
know a better time in general less
stress and probably actually doing more
when they are working and of course
everyone has lived through a pandemic
and is living with the outcomes of this
war that is currently still going on so
Kevin I mean you talked about that
hybrid work model we've arrived at does
it give you empathy for the average work
especially when we look at the younger
Generations the the Gen Z's and
Millennials do you adjust your kind of
bossing if you like for younger
Generations
well we accommodate you know and I'm
dealing with all these CEOs and we have
this narrative every Tuesday we talk to
our companies saying look first of all
we're really surprised that 40 didn't
return we thought it would be 15. that
was the first shock wave we dealt with
and now we have to deal with things like
reducing our footprint in in in office
spaces or retail outlets so a lot of
change going on in the economy and yet
one of the reasons you're seeing markets
like the S P 500 in the US the largest
market in the world Hit new highs is
there's a tremendous amount of
productivity enhancement using
technology through remote work and the
other thing that changed and this is
what people are just starting to figure
out even giant companies like Nike 50 of
our sales now go direct to Consumer
where the margins are much higher and
social media and the data about the
consumer is far more valuable than ever
before so it data is the new oil and
it's come through this new version of
the global economy that I call digital
version 2.0 and margins are much higher
profits are higher cash flows are higher
so we can accommodate a lot of different
work habits as long as they get the job
done when they do it I couldn't give a
beep doesn't matter to me and if they're
doing it at 24 hour cycle somewhere in
Asia or we're talking to them in Dubai
or in Abu Dhabi we don't care and what
we've learned at every other company
started this out this makes us far more
competitive I can hire the best talent
regardless where they are they could be
in the Ukraine and be a great engineer
we don't care as long as they get it
done and I think this is very good for
the globe so yes we have lots of fun on
Tick Tock calling it lazy girl or quiet
quitters nobody cares about that it's
how productive can you be you'll make a
lot of money working wherever you are
whenever you want as long as you get it
done and I think what's interesting
about that as well is that even when
you're not working if you're on social
media you are actually producing value
because you're producing data you're
producing things that can be kind of
um you know analyzed by social media
companies about your habits online that
can produce value and I think that
speaks to this wider trend of actually
the line between life and work becoming
less clear but not creating value for
the boss or directly employs you look
great before we run out of time I just
want to talk about the idea that this is
lazy girl uh because it just seems to be
that it's girls that are making these
videos for you know to attain themselves
um I don't think it's necessarily
relegated just to girls as Kevin said
it's quite quitting but does this not
hark to the idea that women are kind of
taking ownership in the workplace they
sort of think I deserve a break at this
point I think a lot of it has to do with
the idea of branding yourself a lazy
girl
um is potentially easier than a lazy guy
because there's lots of kind of
stereotypes around masculinity which
suggest you have to be going out there
working hard producing for your family
kind of really suffering in order to
basically survive and be a good man and
so I think women this is kind of like a
bit of a it's a bit of a joke really
isn't it it's saying like oh well we
don't care so much about that sort of
thing we're actually not into the idea
of suffering in order to create value
for someone else we believe that you
know we are in control of our lives and
want to be able to have fun basically
Kevin is that fair we can have lazy
girls but not lazy guys
Girls Just Want to Have Fun everybody
knows that you know I I look at it and
say most of my operating positions in My
overall holding company are women so
they they live their lives in this new
Arena the same way men do except they're
incredibly productive which is why I
hire them you know there's an old saying
that I would bring up here you want
something done give it to a busy mother
they're very good at juggling their day
and one of the reasons I support women
entrepreneurs is so many of my companies
are run by women and my operating
positions are women because they get it
done whenever they have to and these
days I don't care what time of the day
that is wonderful look Kevin Grace
thanks so much joining us on the Lazy
Girl debate uncensored next tonight
Andrew Tate takes on Amanda Holden yeah
you heard that correctly the
confidential social media star is
accused of mum shaming talking of mums
Amanda Holden over photos of her in a
bikini that is coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk Rishi sooner
announces new plans for oil and gas
drilling and Promises to stop the war on
motorists GPS are encouraged to refer
patients to life coaches instead of
signing them off sick from work and
husbands Harry been dropped by another
company after being scrapped by Spotify
that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
me Rosanna Lockwood in the chair tonight
I'm joined by the pack in the studio the
Monday night pack associate editor of
the mirror Kevin McGuire talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow and socialist
and author Grace Blakely rejoins us all
of you it's been an interesting show so
what I think it's fair to say women have
been in charge um and even Kevin O'Leary
was a pussycat great I felt so surprised
I was really ready to have a fight with
my my voice completely gone but I didn't
need to no let's stay on the topics
regarding uh women and men shall we
because we talked to you about this
before the break Andrew Tate that uh
very controversial male has made
comments about Amanda Holden um the much
loved celebrity who was posed in a
bikini posted these photos of herself on
holiday she's 52 years old I'm going to
say she looks absolutely incredible uh
if she wants to post a photo of herself
in a bikini and I'm not even gonna say
if her husband approves because who
cares about that but if she wants to do
it that's what she's chosen to do Andrew
Tate tweeted a reply to that saying
quote you are a wife and a mother and
you are far past a teenager there is no
need for this post
um I would argue there is no need for
that comment uh but of course it's
Andrew Tate we're talking about here uh
Kevin no surprises no well look Amanda
Holden go on holiday a post a photograph
he's under house arrest and can't go on
holiday maybe he's just jealous isn't he
I mean look he's a vile horrible book I
didn't actually think about that
actually
violent horrible and there we are if you
post a picture of yourself you're going
to get some comments coming back yeah
but of course look he's he is just fine
he's just a misogynist that's uh it like
another thing in mind this problem is
just she does look great but you know
she also has uh how do I put this nicely
she thought it was more plastic than
Tupperware that being said
that being said when you put when you
put post pictures like that over
yourself online you will get comments
it's the truth now I have no problem
with her posting that because again she
looks she looks better than I do
arguably her body is she's far more to
smooth her diet and physically but
listen this is hard for the course I
think she should be concerned about
being able to move parts of her face
then then part of a very tight talk no
no shame in the circle no shame because
listen it's literally like I feel like
other things the goal is not to look
crazy I have no problem with with doing
enhancing tucking nipping you don't want
to look crazy when you can't move your
face you look crazy so that's that's
what I'll say there but look her body
looks fantastic I mean she looks great
like um like her body yeah neck down
yeah she looks great and I agree it's an
awful man and we shouldn't really be
know that women get a lot of
um a lot of comments about their
physical appearance and that's often why
they feel the need and the pressure to
go onto the knife to have these
procedures in order to look and feel
young and feel accepted I think if
there's people going out there and
sharing pictures of their body with all
of their flaws and everything out to see
we should be encouraging that and yeah
of course you're going to get negative
comments because some people are ready
supporting one another I don't think the
response to insecurity would be to seek
validation online I understand that
there is pressure for women to look a
certain way but I do think it's a
testament to this interaction isn't it
it's about your relationship with
yourself you shouldn't value strangers
comments on that that shouldn't be a
barometer no but we should be able to
say like look here's an example of a
woman showing her body in a way that is
proud and like she's happy with it and
like we should be happy yeah
I just say that the man on the house
arrest doesn't speak for the majority
of the way you're not under house arrest
no no I'm free
let's turn the considerable brains in
this studio to matters a little bit more
serious uh than just talking about
bodies we can talk about body parts all
day I know you know but let's talk about
another story that headlined a lot of
the newspapers today it's regarding this
British man David Hunter uh he was freed
in Cyprus after being sentenced for
manslaughter he um it killed his wife 76
years old he had already spent 19 months
in custody it's an absolutely tragic
story this uh his wife Janice Hunter 74
died of asphyxiation at their retirement
home in Cyprus back in December 2021 now
he wasn't sentenced on murder so no Pro
meditation is what the court decided and
they decided to release him basically on
compassionate grounds here the judge in
Cyprus actually talking about the fact
that love played such a huge part in
this
um Janice had a rare type of blood
cancer and was in a lot of pain and it
obviously brings to mind this
complicated debate about euthanasia
Cyprus will remind ourselves as a Greek
Orthodox country which makes this
incredible be tough to consider and very
different from the considerations we
have here in the UK but Kevin I mean
do you think this will reignite debates
about assisted dying because in Europe
it is allowed in some countries it is
it's not allowed in the UK it certainly
isn't in Cyprus which is a socially
conservative I think it's a debate we
we do need uh because you sometimes
condemn people to live and they want to
end their life and certainly in the UK
if you've got the money in the
organization you can go to Switzerland
dignitas you're okay your family won't
be prosecuted for taking you out and
bringing you back in fact a friend of
mine went and ended her life because she
didn't want the grisly end with Ms that
was ahead of her and those who returned
who had taken of their there was no
action taken against him but I think
we've just got to address it because
yeah because if you love somebody and
they're asking you to help them end
their suffering and their Agony it must
it must be an awful dilemma but but you
will want to help them and you will want
to carry out their wishes I think the
thing is we do have this conversation
regularly in the UK about euthanasia
which I think is a good thing obviously
you don't want the extreme of what's
going on in Canada for instance where
you could argue that people are being
giving euthanasia as an option too
easily I think the issue here is
um obviously the court has decided that
it wasn't murder premeditated murder was
manslaughter
um but when you're talking about it in
the context of euthanasia the issue is
when when you ask for to be to to die to
have for assisted suicide um in
countries that allow this you know there
is a threshold you must meet to be sure
that you have sound mind now obviously
the person
um that would testify to this I don't
know if she left a letter or anything
like that it's not alive to be assessed
by someone other than the person who's
trying to get off
um this charge of murder so I think
that's the issue here is the fact that
he said obviously she wanted it but you
know it's not just the fact that she
wanted it has it been it has it been
sustained that she was of sound mind to
say that she wanted it this is why you
know this often happens with things that
people need or want which are made
illegal it's the the boundary between
something that's regulated and
accessible versus something that's
illegal
um becomes you know the problem because
if you had a system in which there was a
sister dying that was regulated that you
were made sure that for example people
weren't being put under pressure by
their families for inheritance or
depression by medical
um you know associations or if they have
all their mental faculties exactly it's
really difficult you know you have a
system which is it's regulated if you
just basically say people are allowed to
kill people when they are asked to do so
that's obviously a feasible framework
when my dad was on the way out I wished
we could have helped him three months
out if it had been a dog or a cat we
wouldn't have allowed him to suffer the
way he had to yeah but a dog or a cat
fundamentally holds different value to a
human being like a human life is more
valuable than a chicken
fundamentally that is why we shouldn't
have allowed him to Suffer Well yeah I
understand that I think in this
particular case it's more of just the
fact that the person who would testify
to her own sound mind is no longer here
and there's a vested interest for this
man to not be it's impossible
is it is it a Hallmark of civilized it's
like I'm not saying that the countries
that don't have this in place are not
civilized but is it a debate that should
be had I think it is because yeah I mean
this you know what is the difference
between a cat and a dog and a person
like we have decision making
capabilities and you know a conscious
understanding of our own suffering not
just the suffering itself but the fact
that we are likely to continue to
experience it which is what often makes
things so terrible people we brought
that back to a vaguely serious
conversation I'm very impressed Grace
Esther Kevin thank you very much for
joining me in the studio tonight the
Monday night panel that is it from me
for today whatever you're up to make
sure it's uncensored I'll see you back
in this chair tomorrow night good night
have a good one
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this war is making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
King Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedies